[MUSIC PLAYING]
JULIE HANNA: Hello everyone.
Welcome.
My name is Julie Hanna.
I'm executive chair
of the board at Kiva.
I'm a venture partner
at Obvious Ventures.
And I'm also an advisor
to X, formerly known
as Google X, Alphabet's
Moonshot Factory.
And as you all
know, with me here
is Astro Teller, the
captain of Moonshots.
We're here to talk about
responsible innovation--
or Astro, as you prefer to
say lasting innovation--
and how you've
engineered that at X.
Having had the
opportunity to spend time
with you over the
past year, I have
to say it's a fascinating
and remarkable place.
Not just because of your
mission to repeatedly produce
moonshots, like the driverless
cars or stratospheric internet
balloons, but also because
the scale and scope
of what you're trying to do.
So tell us about X. It's
a little bit of a secrecy
about it and mystique.
Why does it exist?
Why does the world need
a Moonshot Factory?
What's the impact you're
seeking to have in the world?
ASTRO TELLER: So X was
created before there
was something called Alphabet.
But the founders of
Google, Larry and Sergey,
had a vision that
over time, we were
going to want this
thing which is now
called Alphabet to
take on meaningfully
new problems in the world.
That doesn't mean that
Google itself can't
take on new problems
in the world,
but they're probably problems
that Google would either never
get to or would
get too much later.
And so setting up a separate
thing, which was originally
called Google X and
now called X, to go
find some of those problems
to care about in the world
that Google at least wasn't
currently working on,
and then to try to find unusual,
unexpected ways of trying
to help solve those problems,
and then the technology
that would make that science
fiction sounding product
or service actually happen--
maybe hopefully-- to
help solve that problem.
That's what X was set up to do.
So X's product is not so
much a thing as businesses.
So alphabet gives us money.
We spend a lot of time
going through this process.
And then very occasionally,
out the other side of X
comes something-- either like
Google Brain that goes back
to Google, or something like
Verily, the life science
business is for Alphabet, or
Waymo, the self-driving car
business for Alphabet, Loon, the
stratospheric balloon project
that you mentioned for
Alphabet, those kinds of things.
That's our product, the
thing that we produce
after we go through a
very long process of sort
of exploring and trying
to find these things.
JULIE HANNA: So as
I eluded to earlier,
you prefer this term
lasting animation
to responsible innovation.
What about that distinction
is important to you?
ASTRO TELLER: Well,
I wouldn't want to--
I appreciate the question.
I wouldn't want it to
sound like we're not
interested in being
responsible in our innovation,
but I prefer the term
lasting innovation.
My concern is if
you believe today
that you're going to
do some innovation,
and that all you need to
check the responsible box
is to sort of look
inside yourself and say,
do I have good intentions?
Yep, I'm responsible.
Check, done.
I don't think that
that's the alpha
and the omega of the actual
obligation of a group doing
innovation.
I think the real issue is
whether in the long term
society is happy with the thing
that you put into society.
If they are, even if it was a
little painful on the way in,
you have some obligation
to help reduce that pain,
but it's probably worth it.
And in the long run, no matter
how good your intentions
were, if it doesn't
work out very well, who
cares that you felt responsible
on the day you were making it?
JULIE HANNA: So a
lot of people would
argue that it's hard enough
to build a product that people
will use in the here and
now, much less something
that's going to be relevant
over the long term,
and that thinking proactively
about the impact of products
that we build is a tax on
innovation in the wild,
as we like to do in Silicon
Valley and Velocity.
What do you say to that?
Why do you think it's important
for us technologists to think
about enduring innovation?
When's the right time
to think about it?
Is it from the onset
after your products
have been successful
in the market?
Constantly?
Whose job is it?
Should companies be
hiring ethicists?
Is that everybody's job?
Both?
ASTRO TELLER: You're
probably going
to ask a whole bunch
of those things
over again because
there were about
six different interesting
questions in there.
But the first one
is it really depends
what your time horizon is.
If you're going to declare
victory or defeat over six
months or a year, whatever.
Go make furbies, whatever it is.
By the time people
are actually angry,
you'll be out of the business.
At X, we happened to have picked
a very long time horizons.
So when we talk
about speed at X,
we're very serious
about going quickly,
but we're measuring that speed
over a very long time horizons.
So if we very quickly
make something
that ultimately society is
going to reject like a bad organ
transplant, that's
not really going fast.
That's a lot of motion, but it's
not actually a lot of progress.
Once you come to terms
with the implications
of these super
long time horizons
and commit to the
concept of lasting, then
what should we do first?
What counts is going quickly
right now is usually what
are the things that we
can do that will cause
us to learn today and
head off at the past
as many long distance
failure modes as we can,
and seeing through that
lens, thinking about the way
that society is going to
experience our innovations
as we birth them into
the world, is actually
critical to 10 or 15 year
thinkings on velocity.
Not in opposition to it.
You were just asking should
we be hiring some ethicists?
I have a slightly odd sounding
maybe response to that.
We have no ethicists
on staff, and that's
very much on purpose.
But that's not because we
don't care about the problem.
I really don't like
the idea though.
You all, you're in
charge of making stuff.
You guys, I'm going
to hire you to gauze
them to be good human beings.
That just doesn't seem like
it's going to work out.
What if we were to
make some stuff,
and we were to agree ahead
of time that it wasn't going
to count as us doing a good job
unless the things that we made
were ultimately really
positive for society?
Then none of us has
ethicist as our title,
but we are all practicing
a lot of the thinking that
goes into doing the moral
math and not just finance
math around the products or
services that we're making.
JULIE HANNA: Yeah, I heard
a little clap over there.
And I have to say I echo that.
I think it's a
refreshing evolution
of the cultural mindset
we've had in the valley.
And it stands in stark
contrast with the culture
of experimentation, where
our attitude has been hey,
if you don't get it right,
you can only fix it later.
After all, it's just bits.
And we can just iterate and
kind of fail forward fast
as we like to say.
But what we're finding
now is that as bits go so
do atoms, that our digital lives
shape our physical reality.
And as a result,
everything's being refactor--
the way we communicate,
collaborate,
the way we make love and
war, Tinder anyone, drones,
whether we work.
And if the future of work
is that work is finished,
perhaps our identities
are being refactor to.
And it's raising really
some fundamental existential
questions like who am I,
and where do I belong,
and who is my tribe, and who has
the right to be in that tribe?
Not to mention the fragile
state of the planet.
So I think we, in
some ways, are still
grasping the far reaching
effect of the products
that we've unleashed
on the world.
And in many cases,
iterating after the fact
really essentially means dealing
with the damaging effects
of the products that
we have released.
As creators, as an industry,
we are really grappling,
I think, to how to become more
proactive rather than kind
of entirely reactive and
experimental and our discovery.
What I find fascinating
when we talk about this
is that this is far from an
intellectual exercise for you.
In fact, I dare say it's
the longest running thread
in your life.
Your journey is a
fascinating study
in intergenerational innovation.
You have quite a family legacy.
And I don't think it's
an underrated statement
to say that it
profoundly changed
the arc of human history.
I can't help but
think it figures
prominently in the person
that you've become.
So tell us a little bit
about your familial lineage
and how it shaped your
philosophy and views.
ASTRO TELLER: There's a lot
in that too, but you're right.
It has had a big impact on me.
So my father's father
was Edward Teller--
colloquially referred to as the
Father of the Hydrogen Bomb.
He helped start Lawrence
Livermore Labs up the road
here, The Star Wars
Defense Initiative.
He was a world-class
scientist, but he was also
excommunicated from the
scientific community
for his work on
some of the weapons.
And so he was held up by
some people in society
as one of the worst human
beings on the planet.
He also grew up in World War
I and then in World War II.
And he saw the horrible
things that humans
are willing to each other.
And this country adopted
him as an immigrant.
And he believed that for
all this country's flaws,
it was the best
country in the world,
and that finding a way to
protect democracy, and protect
freedom, and to put strength
into the hands of people
who could be trusted with it
was a humanity saving exercise.
And there are roughly
as many people
who see him as one
of the greatest
human beings in history
as one of the worst
human beings in history.
And I'm not so much
taking a position on it
as I watched him wrestle
with these things about what
his obligation to the world was.
He didn't want to
spend his time on this.
He wanted to just
be a scientist.
And he was incredibly
sad for much of his life
for having been excommunicated
from the scientific community.
But he felt like he owed it to
the world to help in these ways
that he could.
My mother's father
was the modern founder
of microeconomics.
He won a Nobel Prize in 1983.
And he was manic depressive.
And I watched him profoundly
influence his field,
but not really enjoy it,
and set as many fires
I think as he put out honestly.
I watched these two people
go through their lives
and have an impact on the world,
and thought it's definitely not
going to be easy.
Some of the lessons
they've learned,
I can sort of take
on and maybe take
a path that will hurt a little
less, or maybe net a little bit
more to the positive
in the world.
I really became a
deep believer partly
because of them, and because I
was the dumb one in the family.
Not just the two of them, it was
other people too unfortunately.
So I ended up becoming a deep
believer early in my life
in the power of teams rather
than the power of individuals,
because my skills were more
in helping to organize people
so that we could do something
exciting together rather than
believing that my ideas are just
better than everyone else's.
JULIE HANNA: Thank
you for sharing that.
I think that there's
a subtext in what
you're kind of saying here
and in the conversations
we've had over the
years, that part
of sustainable or
enduring innovation
is that it holds
itself accountable,
not just its shareholders,
but to all stakeholders,
to employees, to customers, to
the communities in which you
operate, and to
society at large.
And I think this
ultimately comes
down to what the positive
and negative impacts are
on each stakeholder
being thoughtful,
proactive, and
reactive about that.
And I do believe that enduring
innovation and ethical practice
involves that kind
of courage to be
hostile to our own mindsets,
the kind of courage
that I think you've sort of
marshalled in response to some
of the things you're just
talking about and witnessing
your family members.
Catching ourselves in the
act of making assumptions,
becoming aware of our
blind spots, a willingness
not just to ask the
question we love
to ask in Silicon Valley, which
is just how big can this get?
What's your world
domination strategy?
But also kind of how
could this go very wrong?
And what would we do about it?
What do we believe is our
role and responsibility
when things don't go as
we had imagined them to?
I think it requires both radical
honesty and radical empathy,
because at its essence,
this question comes down
to human suffering--
the willingness to say, are
the products and businesses
that we're creating
contributing to human suffering
in the short, medium,
and long term?
I mean, it's really
fascinating because we
talk a lot about surprising
and delighting users.
That's become a widespread
design goal in the products
and apps that we build.
But why wouldn't we make
alleviating human suffering
a goal too?
ASTRO TELLER: If I may, I
agree with what you're saying,
but it's further
complicated by the fact
that most technologies
produce diffuse benefits
and concentrated harm.
And the harm tends
to be front-loaded,
and the benefits of technology
tend to be back and weighted.
So in the early
days of technology,
the thing that is most
evident is that harm.
It's like everyone in the
world is going to get $1,
and these 20 people are
going to lose their job.
Society has netted
to the positive,
but some real compassion is
owed to those 20 people who
are going to lose their job.
And no one is going to
picket about how happy they
are for getting $1,
but those 20 people
will picket about the fact
that they're losing their job.
And if we as society
don't empathize with them,
understand where
they're coming from,
and find some way to support
them through this process,
they're rational to
picket about this process.
But then they're
accidentally impeding
this huge net positive society
overall stands to gain.
So I think that we have some
more sophistication and nuance
that we have to get
to as a society about
appreciating where
the benefits go,
where's the harm lands, looking
at these long time horizons,
because it's not the same answer
on week one, or on year one,
or year 50.
JULIE HANNA: No.
ASTRO TELLER: And being able
to tease these things apart
is critical for us to do
thoughtful assessments
of whether a
technology is worth it
and ultimately
good for the world,
and also how to take care of
the people who are losing out
in this process,
so that no one is
enough of a loser in
the trade that society
is making, that they're
willing to fight the process.
They feel lifted up by it.
JULIE HANNA: Yep.
Thank you for that refinement.
That frame of sort of
concentrated benefit diffuse
harm I think is
really excellent.
I would add to that one of
the more latent discoveries
we have is sort of diffuse
harm that's very subtle.
For example, waking up
and discovering that we're
addicted to our phones.
That actually has
long roots going
back to when
BlackBerry became was
sort of the popular
device of the moment.
I remember having a board member
who came to me meeting one day
and declared, I've thrown
away my BlackBerry.
Why?
He said, I was
putting my son to bed.
And I had my arm around
him reading to him.
And I caught myself with
my BlackBerry reading it
while I was in bed with my son.
And I remember
thinking it's either
my son or the BlackBerry.
And yet that's
been 15 years ago.
And we've been on this
kind of slow, steady march.
So that diffuse
concentrated benefit harm,
diffuse you benefit harm is
actually really useful frame.
Back to actually kind
of some of the ways
that you've instrumented
X to address
some of these challenges.
One of the most
striking things that I
find about the culture
at X is how hard you all
work to proactively
understand precisely
these kinds of impacts.
You talk about creating
tight feedback loops
to look at choices,
and consequences,
and unanticipated
consequences in the real world
as early as possible.
And that's kind of
hard when you're
doing Moonshot kind of stuff.
You call it sandboxing.
So how do you
sandboxing at X. Tell us
a little bit about that.
ASTRO TELLER: Sure.
Let me take a step back, so that
it'll seem more motivated why
we do this.
So one of the things I just
mentioned a few minutes ago,
I just don't happen to
believe that any of our ideas
are particularly
better than random.
It's not an attack
on any one of us.
I just don't think my ideas
are much better than random
or your ideas or your ideas.
What I think that we
as a group could do--
what any group could do
if they practiced at it--
would be to get somewhat
more efficient at weeding
through ideas and discovering
of this big mountain of ideas
that we can put in front of us.
If you get a bunch
of smart people,
and you don't make them feel
stupid for putting ideas
on the table, most of
us are pretty creative.
We were when we were six.
You've just forgotten
how, most of us.
But we can find it
again in ourselves.
Let's get this huge pile of
creative ideas on the table.
And then let's pick
them back off the table
and say, how fast, how
thoughtfully, how cheaply
could we discard this
for the right reasons?
Because almost
everything that's on that
table is not going to make it.
So you have to
start by saying, why
don't people do that weeding
process really efficiently?
And there are a set of
reasons why they don't.
We can get back to why
they don't, but if you just
buy into the idea that the
real process of innovation
isn't even really filling
out the table with ideas--
that's actually
relatively easy to do.
It's the efficiency with which
you're discarding the ideas--
then you want to try stuff
because that's how you learn.
But especially if you're serious
about lasting innovation,
you don't just want to
throw it out in the world
and let the world
essentially pay
the consequences for the fact
that you didn't think first.
That doesn't work very well.
There needs to be
something in between where
you expose your idea to
reality step by step.
If you can prove that it
breaks the Law of Physics,
on the whiteboard, you don't
need to build a prototype
and put it in the world.
You just like satisfy yourself.
The Second Law of Thermodynamics
is probably smarter
than you are.
And you throw out the
idea, and you move on.
If it doesn't sort of die on
one of those straightforward
kind of white paper fronts, then
maybe you do build a prototype.
But you could test
it on your roof.
You don't actually have to
go and tested in the middle
of some public square first.
Let it suffer from physics,
or show it to one customer
and say, what do you think?
The first customer's
probably going to tell you
it's not right.
You don't need to give
it to 100,000 to find out
that it's not quite right yet.
And each of these
steps along the way,
you want to get more in
touch with the real world.
But to use the
self-driving car metaphor,
you want to keep your
hands close to the wheel,
so you can get the learning
without actually endangering
the people around you.
That's what I mean
by sandboxing.
And that's both learning
about the product
in terms of its
financial possibilities,
but also in terms of the
purpose that you hope it has
in the world.
Because you may learn
along the way oh
this isn't solving
the problem I thought
even if people will pay for it.
Or it's solving the problem.
I thought it was going to solve,
but it has these really nasty
unintended consequences.
I guess we need to change
our product if we're
serious about actually having
this ultimately be held up
by society as a good thing.
So that by the
time we're serious
and it's out there
in the world, it's
had most of its sort of
failure modes weeded out of it.
JULIE HANNA: Yeah.
It's fascinating.
It's like a Back to
the Future moment.
Back in the day when I first
began building products
in the prehistoric
pre-internet days,
we used to do limited betas.
And then when the
internet came along,
we said, hey, the
world can be our beta.
I Remember when
Gmail first released.
It was like it was in
beta for five years.
And now, what we're
realizing is we're
running a social experiment
on two billion people, right?
And we're realizing
how that can unleash
a devastating social impact.
That's really hard.
And I think some
of us are wondering
if it's even possible
to recover from it.
You talk about sandboxing,
but in contrast,
you also say that
Silicon Valley is not
the place to learn about the
impact of your products--
especially at scale.
That it's important to get
out of the bubble and really
understand our full impact.
Can you talk about
some examples of how
X has done that and some
of what you've learned?
ASTRO TELLER: Sure.
So for many of our projects, we
do some testing in California
and the United States.
But we have more balloons
flying for our Loon project,
more balloons over Africa
right now than over the United
States, more balloons
over South America
right now than over
the United States.
And that's partly because
there's a lot that we
can learn by talking to people.
If our goal is to
connect the unconnected,
there are a lot more unconnected
people in those places.
And there are things
I didn't know.
I think most of the people
on the Loon team didn't know.
Like for example,
it turns out there
are people who have connectivity
according to the statistics.
But it turns out there are
people across the world--
particularly in South
America, this is a thing.
They build tree houses
with ladders up to them.
And then entrepreneurs
rent this platform out
by the minute to other
people who go up there,
because it's a
place from which you
can get a cell signal, which is
unbelievable entrepreneurship.
I absolutely love it.
But to understand that counts
as having connectivity.
Not the person who owns the
platform but every person who
is paying to leave their
town, go to the special tree,
climb up the ladder, and
get their connectivity.
I didn't know this
was a service.
It turns out there are
trucks and motorbikes that
come through the fields.
It's probably in Africa too.
I happen to know this is
prevalent in South America.
And they collect
everyone's cell phone.
And then they go
to the city center,
where there's a Wi-Fi hotspot.
And they just sit there
for a little while.
And then all the text
messages download.
All the sent messages upload.
And then they drive
back out to the field.
And they distribute the phones.
This is a service that
people get paid for,
and these people
have connectivity.
But if you don't
actually go to the places
where the people are
that you're helping,
you don't really understand
their current solution set
or what they would count as
enough better in the right ways
that it would make a
difference to them.
It's not obvious.
If balloons are just sometimes
there and sometimes not,
would that change
their lives or not?
You shouldn't make that up.
You should go talk
to these people
and probably eventually
try it with them.
And we do the same thing.
Our self-flying vehicles
for package delivery,
Wing, is ramping up service
in Finland and in Australia,
a little bit here in
the United States.
One of the things that we
discovered in Australia--
I don't know.
Probably not particular
to Australia--
is we were confident
that the sound
of it going up or
coming down was going
to be what annoyed people.
And then when it went over,
that wouldn't annoy people.
It turns out that people,
for whatever reason,
even though it's
technically quieter,
notice the buzz when
it goes by more.
OK.
That can surprise
us, but we can't
like argue to them with
a sound meter, no no, no.
You're wrong.
You're not annoyed.
Look at the number here.
You can't be annoyed.
That's not how the world works.
The way the world works is
we have to say, oh, thank you
for the feedback.
And then we make our
self-flying vehicles quieter
because that's what
we owe society,
so that they will be excited and
accept the delivery vehicles.
JULIE HANNA: This is
near and dear to me
because as an immigrant and as
a refugee, my work with Kiva
takes me to parts
of the world where
people live on very little,
as little as $1 a day.
I'm always reminded how easy
it is to forget being here
in Silicon Valley,
the digital divide,
and how that really shapes our
lives in very different ways.
And that really solving
humanity's greatest challenges
and building technology for
the many, not just the few,
means understanding that
divide fully in the ways
that you're talking about.
And at the same time,
being here in the valley,
here at Google I/O, a place
where the sky is literally
the limit, it's an
incredibly hopeful feeling.
We can actually say
and do things here
that have an impact
around the world.
Those of us who've made our
way into this literal room,
I mean, we can say
and do things that
will impact the lives of
millions and even billions--
either directly or indirectly.
So really, it it's just
a reminder of that adage
as Silicon Valley goes,
so does the world.
With that, I guess I find great
meaning and purpose in that--
not just the burden
of responsibility--
to have that kind of leverage.
There's a great pride
of identity in that.
And I think that if we all
embrace that more fully,
it's really exciting to think
of what can be unleashed.
To be in that kind
of position, there's
a great privilege that is
afforded to a very few people.
And it's all the more
reason why having diversity
of thought and
experience is just
so essential in the
process of innovation.
One of the things I've
drawn great inspiration from
is the explicit
commitment that X
has to diversity and inclusion.
You have a fascinating range
of disciplines and backgrounds,
and ethnicities and genders,
and experiences at the table,
and more than any tech culture
I've actually ever encountered.
It's clearly a
values-driven choice,
but also you view it
essential to X's ability
to be successful.
why do you see diversity
and inclusion so crucial
to Moonshot success?
ASTRO TELLER: I'll
give you two answers.
But before I give
you the two answers,
let me just flag that working
towards diversity inclusion
is just the right thing to do.
And even if that doesn't
tend to change the world--
and it makes me sort of
sad that it doesn't--
I just want to flag that
is the right thing to do,
and that secretly makes
me feel really good.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Let's put that on the
side for a second.
The second reason
is, let's say you're
a creativity factory as much
as you are an engineering
factory, which is what we are.
So we want a perspective shift.
We literally want to
see things differently
from how other people see them.
If we fill up the building
with any particular ethnicity,
but let's say for
argument's sake white men,
we're going to have
fewer perspectives.
We're just going to see things
less differently than if we
have people who are
different ages, who
come from different
countries, who have
different ethnic backgrounds.
People who've been in the
military have an experience
that people haven't been
in the military don't have.
We want every kind of that
sort of cognitive diversity
that we can get.
I just see this as an arbitrage.
If the world is
biased and bigoted,
and we're somewhat less
by ended and bigoted
than the rest of the
world, then we're
just going to blap
them, because we're
getting the benefit that they
just aren't realizing is there.
So that's one of the
practical reasons,
leaving the actual
social justice
thing on the side for a second.
Separately, in terms
of lasting innovation,
I was making this joke.
You guys are going to
work on the product,
and then you're going to
get them to be good people.
Part of the process of doing
moral math on whether what
you're doing is
right is you need
to get more voices in the room.
So either we're
going to have a bunch
of limited perspectives
in our building,
and then we'll build stuff.
And then we're going to have
to very after the fact, very
laboriously, go get those
other voices to tell us
what we were missing.
Or crazy idea-- since it turns
out it's good business anyway--
if we had those diverse
voices in our building
from the beginning,
we don't need
to outsource groups to tell us
what we're missing nearly as
much, because they're literally
part of the process of making
these things.
And so we catch a lot
of the sort of oddities
of how we think about
things and the points
that we're missing
that way the real world
works much faster and
much more naturally
than if we had to outsource
discovery of our blind spots
after the fact.
JULIE HANNA: Yeah.
What it brings to mind is this.
We've had this trope
for a long time
that technology
is neutral, which
I think has kind of been a
blind spot for us frankly.
Tech may be neutral, but the
products that we build with it
or not.
They very much shape our
intentions and our biases
as you point out.
And we see that playing it
out in all kinds of ways--
whether it's facial recognition
software that doesn't recognize
dark-skinned people,
or the fact that it
took 30 years to get the
car companies to test
with female crash test dummies.
And women were being injured and
killed far more often than men
in cars.
When you think about the way
that this actually played out,
what are some ways that
diversity is actually
shaped the course of
a Moonshot project?
ASTRO TELLER: I'm just going to
give you the first thing that
came to my mind.
This happens to be
more practical one
than an ethical one.
So when Loon is
building these balloons,
they're not as big as
this room, but they're
about the size of a house.
But they're thinner
than a trash bag,
and they have to cost
less than the cost
of a trash bag per square
meter, because we're
going to put these things up.
They have to stay up for
many hundreds of days
in order for this to work
and be an actual replacement
to satellites.
How do you do that?
There's literally no one in
the world knows how to do that.
And one of the people
who's been most profoundly
influential in the design--
And these balloons are
very complicated because we
stick helium in them.
But we actually are
also sticking air
in a separate bag
inside the balloon--
call it a ballonet--
to make it heavier when we want.
And then we get the
air back out when
wanted make it light again.
So these have multiple
different compartments.
They have to undergo huge
temperature ranges between day
and night of about 150 degrees.
So when they're the hottest,
they were super, super tight.
So there's an
architectural aspect to it,
but there's also because
they're like super thin fabric.
And we have to make them
when they're deflated.
It turns out a
fashion designer--
she has been with the
project maybe six years now--
has been one of the most
profoundly influential
in the evolution of what this
thing is, of how we make it,
of what we make
it out of, of how
we study it before we launch
it, so that we can find flaws
in it.
And it actually now has sort of
elements and aspects of design
from the fabric trade,
which I seriously
doubt that we otherwise
would have gotten to.
And there are just hundreds
of those kinds of examples
that naturally happen for
free when you get people
with various
experiences in the room.
JULIE HANNA: That's great.
So the team at X sometimes
calls you a cultural engineer.
And to my eye, you do these
really interesting things
that I call them teaching
principles, sort of hack
the organizational mindset.
A lot of it's
around getting them
to hold these tensions of
what are seeming opposite,
like being passionately
dispassionate, responsibly
irresponsible, and perhaps most
of all, audacity with humility.
Talk a little bit
about these principles
and how you see them as
being critical to the process
of innovation.
ASTRO TELLER: I think that
it's sort of a natural state
for most human beings.
We want simplicity
and we want clarity.
And so we pick on any particular
spectrum, one of the polls.
Because we pick a poll,
you can't get any farther.
It's easy to
describe, and it tends
to be the case that is not the
optimal point on that spectrum.
So the last one that you
just described for example,
I deeply believe that
for ethical reasons
and also for
practical reasons, we
should have huge
amounts of audacity at X
and huge amounts of humility.
If you only have humility, we'd
probably never try anything,
so we'd never
accomplish anything.
If you only have
audacity, you're
going to make a large mess,
and you're not going to care.
If you have a lot of audacity
and a lot of humility
though, while that seems
like it's a tension
to hold, hopefully
if we do it right,
it's going to feel like this.
I believe we can try anything.
Let's try this and despite
how crazy it sounds.
Then as soon as we try it,
let's have the humility,
because almost all of
the time the answer
is that didn't work very well.
We have to be able
super easily to say
that didn't work very well.
What did we learn?
What could we do
better next time?
And it's a positive
feedback cycle
that allows us both to
try things and learn
from our mistakes
rather than trying
to pick one of those polls.
You mentioned responsibly
irresponsible,
which I think is
another good example.
I have the bumper
sticker on my laptop,
and a number of other
people do at X. It
says Save the Oompa Loompas.
And this is my way
of reminding people
about being responsibly
irresponsible.
And what I mean by that is if
you let the oompa loompas just
do whatever they wanted,
they just go crazy.
They'd rip the place apart.
There would be no
chocolate factory.
Creativity unharnessed and
undirected is not very useful.
On the other hand,
extreme amounts
of rigor and responsibility is
the death of real creativity.
You need to find this
place in the middle
where you encourage
people to be unnatural,
to be weird, to try
things, to be silly,
and to be wrong
most of the time,
but to create some shaping and
guardrails of responsibility
that tends to cause
that creativity
to head in positive directions.
That's another one
of those tensions,
that if you were to
pick either extreme,
you would get a pale
shadow of the benefit
that you can get if you hang out
in that uncomfortable tension
point in the middle.
JULIE HANNA: Yeah.
One of the tensions, I
think, we as an industry
are reckoning with the sort
of the tension between speed
and ethics.
The era of move fast
and break things
has come to a screeching
halt or an abrupt damned.
You hear talk of
minimum viable product
now being moving to
minimum virtuous products.
So this notion of harmonizing
seeming opposites I
think in many ways,
it helps us break down
the dualistic extremes
that are much easier
to gravitate towards,
but ultimately
yield a much greater impact.
Speaking of dualistic
mindsets, one
of the things that we've had a
long running conversation about
is purpose and profit.
They tend to be sort of
pitted against each other.
And we share the view that
technology and business
are the most powerful tools
for solving humanity's biggest
challenges.
As sometimes you
say, the world is
on fire and tech can put
out some of those fires.
I would also add that
despite our good intentions
that we're making the
world a better place, we
as technologists have started
some of the most profound fires
right now.
So it's a good reminder
that intentions are
necessary, but not sufficient.
In a time when people feel that
our pursuit of profit has come
at a great cost to humanity--
much less what we see with
climate change--
it's a conversation that we
need to have more than ever.
How do you think about the
relationship between purpose,
profit, and lasting innovation?
ASTRO TELLER: I
don't buy the story
that they're in fundamental
conflict with each other.
I believe that things that make
money get bigger over time.
And things that lose money
tend to get smaller over time.
So if you have a
magic box that's
going to cure cancer, or create
clean water for the developing
world or whatever that
is, and it loses money,
I have news for you.
It's not going to help.
No one's going to
have one of your boxes
because you can't get those
boxes out in the world enough
if you're losing
money on every box.
So profit is, at an
absolute minimum,
the wind beneath the wings
of the purpose motive.
On the other hand, who
wants to spend their lives
making money and then
feeling empty about it
because you didn't
actually help the world?
You just moved some money
from somebody else's pocket
to your pocket.
couldn't live that way.
I presume most people couldn't.
Crazy idea.
What if we found the
intersection of those two
things?
I think there are plenty of
problems in the world where
if you just focus on
solving, or helping to solve,
that particular
problem in the world,
and trust that
the business model
is going to come into focus
over time, if you were really
solving--
This happens at X all the time.
Someone comes and
says, this is going
to solve this huge
problem in the world,
but no one's going
to pay us for it.
And I say why?
That doesn't make
any sense to me.
If you really can solve
a problem the world,
let's go for it,
because I just believe
that if we're solving
a problem the world,
people are going to
pay us fairly for it.
Now if you have
to give someone $1
and it's going to cost
us $1, tend to give them
the $1, that doesn't scale.
But I think that
there are plenty
of things at that
intersection where
you can be driven by
the desire to solve
an actual problem in the world.
And you may have to
pivot along the way.
You might be wrong.
And you were determined
to do it using
and lifted up by
the profit motive.
I think that's the
best case scenario.
JULIE HANNA: One of my favorite
things about being at X
are these conversations
that we have.
And it always brings to mind
the William Gibson quote,
"The future is already
here, but it's just
not evenly distributed."
I always feel like I'm visiting
the future when we talk,
and it's the future
that I want to live in.
It's a future also
that understands
the importance of bringing
the massive advantages
of technology and business
to all of humanity,
and a conversity bringing more
of our humanity to the way
that we do business
and innovate.
So thank you for provoking,
inspiring, and educate us
as you always do.
ASTRO TELLER: Thank you, Julie.
Thank you to everyone here.
Thank you for listening.
Thank you Judy.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]